we ignored the warning shots
of sars and murs and zika and a whole
bunch of other things
kovid is a very very difficult warning
shot to miss
the whole world has been traumatized by
this there will be
much greater seriousness applied to
pandemic resistance in the future the
question is
will it be adequate attention and will
it be sustained in tension
and will it be intelligent attention
so i read something on reddit the other
day that i want to
dictate to you here the decision to use
cfcs chlorofluorocarbons
instead of bfcs bromofluorocarbons
was pretty much arbitrary had we decided
to use bfcs
the ozone layer probably would have been
totally destroyed before we even knew
what was happening
killing all life bfcs destroyed the
ozone at over 100 times the rate
of cfcs that's amazing i never heard
that before
how sick's that i mean cfcs were scary
but um obviously they moved slowly
enough that we were
more or less able to fix the problem
before we were all dead
replied and said maybe that was the
great filter that all the other
civilizations just
chose the wrong coolant medium that's
funny
so today we're going to be talking about
existential risk my
favorite terrifying topic and also your
one of your areas of expertise
definitely and it's amazing how
seductive the topic is to a lot of us
it's it's like we can't take our eyes
away from it
we get fascinated like what you just
read to me
this is a probably says something bad
about me psychologically but my main
reaction was like
how cool i mean obviously we dodged the
bullet so that's
pretty nice but like wow another
existential risk that i didn't even know
about
what do you think it is about that
because i have the same fascination
i you know maybe it's something that was
you know drilled into us
when our you know distant ancestors were
growing up on the savannah
maybe there's something about being
fascinated by things that can annihilate
one
oneself um that
conferred some kind of survival
advantage and i'm just riffing here and
i'm just i'm just going to make this
up but you know particularly the
head of the clan the hunter-gatherer
clan whoever the boss was
who chieftain whatever you want to call
that person um
really needed to think about what could
kill us all and the head of the clan
probably was a man and probably fathered
far more children
than people who were not head of the
plan and so
we all have a lot of head of clan dna in
us
i'm making this up as i'm going along
but i like that i like that theory
so we probably do as a statement of fact
all have a lot of head of plan dna
because there were
thousands of generations and the heads
of the clans
were the people who probably had the
most progeny
and the heads of the clans really did
have to think about
not just what could kill me a
saber-toothed tiger on a hunt or
whatever
but what could wipe us all out really
need to think about that
um and the successful ones continue to
have progeny so that's my answer
it's like a we've got the anxiety bias
right that we're more scared of things
than we are hopeful about things
but this is like a macro level version
of the macro level
anxiety about bias exactly we've got it
we've worked it out okay so
all right good given the fact that mean
you're obsessed with it and a ton of
people that are listening will be as
well
why do you think we're so blind to how
close we can come to total
civilizational
destruction generally it's not at the
forefront of what we're talking about
every day
as much as me and you might wish that it
was
well i think it's because it's so new
there was really no plausible step that
i can think of
that humanity could have taken before
let's say the mid-1950s
to wipe everybody out and at that point
it was one thing
so after hiroshima nagasaki there's one
nuclear power the united states
it had precisely two bombs it used them
both
so there's no way to destroy the earth
right then along comes the hydrogen bomb
and there are very few of them and only
the us has them and then the soviet
union gets them and then all of a sudden
there's this insane
push to put them on long-range bombers
missiles and so forth
it's probably late 50s by the time
h-bombs were
proliferate enough and you know two
sides had enough capability that
that truly wiping out society became a
problem
so as a you know quarter million year
old species we've been facing this for
60 years
so it's probably it's even though
what i said about the plan not
withstanding to put it on a global level
that's a pretty new development and
i would also say that the the attention
that's given to
the careful attention academic attention
serious thought
in industry attention governmental
attention is far less of what it should
be but nonetheless
the amount of attention that is given to
existential risk
today to me feels like it's
10 to 30 or even more times what we
what we gave to it uh let's say 15 years
ago and 15 years ago
i don't think people like you and i even
knew the term existential risk
so i think we're developing that muscle
pretty rapidly
at this point and that's a good thing
and hopefully it's not too late
that's your hopeful optimism your
unbeatable optimism coming through there
yeah i'm i'm pathologically optimistic
sometimes
how much of it do you think could be a
hubris as well
you know by definition we haven't
destroyed ourselves yet therefore we're
probably fine at surviving any future
destruction potentials also yeah i mean
the
response to that is like at a boy out of
girl
it's been 60 years um so you've dodged
numerous bullets in 60 years uh
one or two maybe sort of by design
and quite a few more by accident and so
do you want humanity to last another 60
years or do you want it to last another
quarter million years
and if the answer is you've been dodged
you dodged one bullet for
the 40 years and you've dodged
more than one bullet for maybe 20 years
um
is that the kind of track record that
gives you confidence
that the civilization or the species is
going to survive another quarter million
years
that's absurd that's like saying i wish
we could do the proportions and
back of the envelope math could probably
reveal it but that's kind of like saying
one to two seconds into what americans
call a soccer game and the rest of the
world calls a football game
we haven't given up any goals so we're
fine yeah yeah yeah
yeah given the fact that existential
risks generally
don't have a ton of global sort of
attention paid to them
why do you think climate change is given
so much attention
when there's more imminent threats that
aren't even really in the conversation
well i think the attention to climate
change first of all um
developed in a compounding way over a
longer period of time
and so the whole earth catalog the
picture of the earth on it
the first earth day which i think was
1970 etc
you know that's a great deal more time
and i think these things you know like
successful investments
when a school of thought really really
plants its roots and takes off it's like
compounding
returns you know it's like so the number
of people who are environmentally aware
in 1971
was probably pretty small um but
it was it was a meme that the world was
ready to hear
and it had a lot of committed people all
from the very beginning
and that meme spread and it resonated
and more work was done
and that spread it was like an
investment that compounds at 20
per annum like wow 20 per annum
10 years in you know you think you're in
fat city but holy cow
50 years in it's ginormous and so i
think it's
a lot of it is the fact that that
compounding awareness
has had you know more years to grow
exponentially
and then the other thing is you get to a
certain point in any of these fields
and you start developing very
significant industries and economic
interests
around them and so now there is a very
very large number of people
who are making their living off of
protecting us from climate change
whether they're making electric cars
whether they're academics who specialize
in climate models whether they're
politicians
who fired up you know their base and got
elected in part
on that message there is a very very
large interest group that is
believes i'm not saying it's cynical but
believes in this but
is full time committed to making this
stuff work and the number of people who
are
currently full-time committed to
preventing existential risk is probably
a
miniscule handful of academics but that
is a hell of a lot more brain power
persuasion power intellectual output etc
than we had 15 years ago so it's just
starting you think that
first mover advantage for climate change
in that case in
20 years time then we're going to have
the church of nick bostrom and
everyone's going to be praying to the
control problem and looking at
nanotechnology and grey goo
one hopes uh i don't know if nick or i
want there to be a church dedicated to
him we could talk about that
later in the conversation if you wish
but um yeah i think
i think spreading and compounding
awareness of this
is the only thing that will will protect
us
because the policymakers will be the
last ones to the party
but if this becomes something that you
know a million people
are really interested and aware of and
informed about 10 million 100 million et
cetera
that's you know in compounding out and
eventually seeping into government
that's ultimately the only way we can
dodge these bullets you mentioned that
we've had a couple of close calls over
the last 50 years
can you take us through a few of those
stories yeah i mean i think
you know starting um with well first of
all the bfc thing that's a new one and
if that
redditor was correct in what they said
and i'd love it if you could send me
that because
i want to dig into that it's it is
intriguing and frightening
um there's one right there i mean the
ones that are most chilling to me
because i grew up during the cold war
um are the nuclear ones and you know
there
there are a couple of particularly
famous incidents
one during the cuban missile crisis
in which there were nuclear-armed subs
russian subs
patrolling the area outside of cuba as
the american blockade
settled in and one of
the american boats was sending
it's funny they knew the subs were down
there and they didn't want to escalate
so instead of sending depth charges they
were sending something like
practice death charges or something
weird like that but they were dropping
these depth charges and really menacing
these submarines
and there were a lot of american boats
like half the fleet
was in a pretty compact area at this
point and i think there were four
russian subs in the in the submarine
fleet
that were down there and these depth
charges start coming down
and um on one of the subs
they there was a decision to nuke the
american fleet because they had these
nuclear torpedoes
and if they set them up it basically
would have wiped out the american fleet
and in most submarines um
three of the four i believe it required
two people to say yes let's do it in
order for it to be done now you're
under water you got depth charges you're
not on the phone to khrushchev
like these are people who are fully
empowered to start a nuclear war
and the stop gap measure to prevent that
was
not one person but two people have to
say we're gonna do it
on this one particular sub where for
whatever reason i wish i knew the
details better
the decision was being taken there was a
third man
and i'm saying man because i'm sure it
was all men on the russian submarine
crew in the 1960s
there was a third man who got a vote
because he was like the party cadre or
something like he was
he was like the head of the you know the
communist party as opposed to
merely the military you know delegation
of the submarine fleet
and he said no and had that third person
not
been on the submarine or had that third
person said yes the next step would have
been
uh for the russian submarines to fire a
tactical nuke and basically eradicate
that part of the american fleet
now a nuclear weapon has been used
during the cuban missile crisis
and that you know it's
very it's almost difficult to imagine
how that would not have
escalated to doomsday so
holy cow and then the other famous
incident was
the guy i've seen a movie about him i've
heard interviews with him so i should
remember his name do you remember his
name the guy
on the russian side who saw yeah so
another story in the states too i want
to say the 80s
um probably early 80s there was
um a basically the
russian equivalent of norad so basically
um the operation where they detected
incoming american bombers and missiles
and so forth
and they saw american missiles coming
over
and they was like
oh my god it's armageddon has started
there's only one missile
or two or something weird like that and
so it basically went up to the person
who was in charge of that facility
whose name was escaping me and his
instinct told him
this is not the start of doomsday they
wouldn't just send one missile
and then more missiles started showing
up
but it was not an all-out attack and
this guy was in contact with the
superiors in moscow and they said
launch everything and he said no
and his instinct was screaming at him
that this is some kind of something's
gone wrong with our systems they're not
starting they're not going to send two
or three or a handful of missiles over
here
trigger an all-out response if they were
if they were taking a first strike
they'd be setting everything they had
so he stood his ground and did not
launch and had there been somebody
different
almost probably anybody in that role
because the job your job was to say yes
to moscow
your job wasn't to think you know
so that was an unbelievably close call
there was another
less close call that i think a little
bit more is made up than should be
where at norad on the american side
there was
a first strike a pretty full
full-blooded first strike was detected
and it turned out to be
a test sequence and there was actually
journalists in norad when that happened
so there are there are a lot of these
things that we got through by the skin
of our teeth
and these things could still happen i
mean there's still
an inordinate amount of ordinance sorry
for the pun
on the russian and american side and
increasingly on the chinese side
and one hopes that our our safeguards
and our software and our
our protocols have improved since the
80s but i don't know that they have
and you know that risk still sits out
there now i'm focusing on nuclear
because
those are i think those really are the
bullets that we've dodged so far
um we're just getting into the rain the
area in which sin bio
could take us out and particularly with
a rogue actor as a scenario that as you
know i worry about particularly
although bio you know bio terror or bio
error both of them
are very very very dangerous but we're
just getting to the point where
synthetic biology could take us out
and super ai is not there yet um
and i i feel like that's at least a
handful of decades out
um and nano is definitely not there yet
but we're going to have an increasing
number
of these of these risks facing us and
the real danger
is the proliferation of the ability to
hit we'll just call it euphemistically
the flashing red button the hypothetical
probably non-existent
flashing red button that we imagine you
know mr biden and mr putin and mr xi
have at all times available to them to
destroy the world
um when you look at the cold war
let's think of this we spent trillions
of dollars
preventing two people i'm obviously
oversimplifying but preventing two
people from hitting that flashing red
button
what do we spend it on what we spend on
all those detection systems
but we also spent it on enormous
conventional armies to deter
you know you know small acts that could
snowball into large
large conflagrations um we spent money
on
regional wars to prod each other and
test each other and to show resolve and
you know to hold each other at bay the
diplomatic apparatus all these things
were in place to to stop two people from
hitting that button
and those were two people who were
highly inclined
not to hit that button and obviously it
was more than two because we just talked
about scenarios in which people down in
the
chain of command had that power but we
spent a lot of money
making sure that a very small handful of
people
didn't hit that button and so far we've
succeeded we came terrifyingly close but
so far we've succeeded
the danger with things like symbio and
super ai
is that that decision not to do
something
unbelievably dangerous or even something
deliberately destructive
is suddenly going to be in the hands of
thousands of people perhaps in the case
of sin bio i believe it will be
thousands of people
um and probably pretty soon in the case
of super ai it's probably going to be a
smaller group of people
who don't take the right you know
precautions
about not letting the genie out of the
bottle but with sin by i'll focus on
that for a moment
the tools and the methodologies are
improving so rapidly
that the things that only the most
brilliant
academic synthetic biologists at the
pinnacle
of you know laboratory budget equipment
know-how etc things that would elude
that person be impossible for that
person
will be today will be child's play in a
high school bio lab
in quite a bit less than 20 years
because this is an exponential
technology
and that's the frightening thing and
all the wisdom and complexity and the
nobel worthy work
that is done by prior generations
will starts getting embodied in simpler
and simpler and more and more common and
cheaper and cheaper tools
and so all of a sudden all that wisdom
and genius that eludes most of us
is embodied like you know we're talking
on laptops how much
nobel worthy work was done to create
you know the computers that we're using
to speak to one another over many many
generations you and i are
smugly sitting here with computing power
that the most brilliant you know
you know you know computer engineer
electrical engineer
could only dream of you know 25 years
ago
and it's all embodied in this simple
tool and that goes into syn bio tools
in wet labs at lower and lower levels of
academia
and in you know a higher and higher
number of lower and lower budget
companies
we are relying on an impossible number
of people
not to screw up or not to do something
deliberately evil
and if one says well why would somebody
ever do something deliberately evil with
sin bio after we've just been through
the answer is i don't know i don't know
what motivated the columbine kids
i don't know what motivates the
you know more than one mass shooter per
year per day
that strikes to the united states i
don't know what motivates those people
but they're motivated and they're
killing everybody they can
they just don't have tools to wipe us
all out so anyway that was
probably a very long-winded answer but
we're gonna have to worry a great deal
about the ability to do something
catastrophic being
in a lot of hands rather than just two
that we can watch very closely
is that what you call democratizing the
apocalypse
yes that is exactly what i call
democratizing the apocalypse or
privatize i call it
uh both privatizing the apoc apocalypse
and democratizing it
and privatizing you know just drives
home the fact that
saving the world from destruction or
destroying the world is no longer a
public good
you know it's in private hands and so
it's a
slightly playful and slightly perverse
way of putting it
but that game of chicken
that the superpowers played with each
other during the cold war
was quote unquote a public good
for all of the terror that anybody who
grew up under a nuclear threat
and by the way that's everybody alive
right now because that threat is still
very present we just don't feel it the
way we did during the cold war
the terror that anybody felt growing up
with a nuclear threat and it was
billions of people who were some degree
i'm sure traumatized by that
is nothing compared to the horror that
would have been inflicted by more and
more conventional wars
so if conventional wars between the
superpowers you know more vietnam's more
korea wars etc
uh eventually you know followed by an
enormous
world war three smackdown in europe so
imagine nuclear weapons were impossible
it's it's probably likely it's almost i
mean it's highly likely in my mind
looking at the rhythm of geopolitics
stretching from let's say 1840 to 1940
if nukes had never been developed
um it's hard to imagine we wouldn't have
continued to butcher ourselves
in our tens of millions that's a really
good point
imagine just how much massacre there
would have been if we didn't have this
capacity to do
wide scale preventative destruction
yeah so so i am sure that there would
have been an all-out war between
the soviet bloc and the western bloc in
europe probably
in the 50s probably in the 60s without
that
that threat yeah and there probably
would have been far more
vietnam's in in koreas and
stuff we can't even imagine and so that
game of chicken was
quote unquote a public good and it was
owned and operated by governments and
that
most you know terrifying of decisions
was concentrated in a tiny number of
hands
and humanity did shoot those rapids and
we probably would have had a far
far far far far more gory and
traumatizing
second half to the 20th century and to
this day i bet we'd still be clobbering
each other with conventional weapons and
now they're getting to the point that
they're they're terrifying with
automating you know like
so you know public good all of a sudden
and when that suddenly is in private
hands
things change in frightening ways let's
pivot over to super ai risk
um the the parties that
will be in the position at some point in
the future
if super ai is indeed a possibility
which i personally absolutely think it
is
the parties who will be in the position
to
create the genie in the bottle step one
and b
screw up and let the genie out of the
bottle um
or let's just go with the creation step
not maybe they don't know that they're
inches away from creating the genie
those people are
almost certain to be in some form of
private company in my mind
um at least in the united states and
china we know less of what they're doing
there
and there probably are government labs
that are
recruiting extraordinary talent and
proceeding headlong down paths um that
we can't necessarily proceed on i mean
but today the greatest talent in
computing
is not working for you know the united
states government or any government
it's working for you know deep mind it's
working for google it's working for
startups that we're not aware of
and that means that the person or people
who are in a position to say ooh that's
really risky
huh but it's kind of tempting
they have huge economic incentives
to take what they might perceive to be a
tiny risk
and you know probably get away with a
tiny risk
and you know as a result of that be
gazillionaires
you know that economic incentive did not
exist for anybody who felt like they
were chancing it
with nuclear armageddon we don't have to
worry about putin saying oh it's kind of
risky
if i take this insane step and like
invade the rest of
the ukraine from the eastern ukraine
could lead to nuclear war but uh i get
an ipo and i'm rich if it doesn't you
know that that incentive isn't there
if it's a public good and so what i
worry about
is lots and lots of private actors
taking
what might be like oh it's a sliver of
one percent risk that the world
ends but that's not going to happen um
or it probably won't happen and if it
doesn't happen and let's face it it
probably won't
holy cow here comes glory and suddenly
there's
much much much more incentive for lots
and lots of people to take tiny tiny
risks
that could kill us all and that's why
the privatization really really worries
me
it's because you've got privatized gains
but socialized losses socialized losses
exactly private that's what that was our
economic crisis right the financial
crisis
for years people in various positions in
wall street on the buy side on the sell
side on the fun side all kinds of things
were taking odious risks with the world
economy
and getting great returns because you
know higher risk leads to higher returns
in finance and so they were inhaling
money for themselves and putting them
into super yachts at picasas
and then when everything fell apart the
bill came due to us
all of us financial crisis that bailout
was
the cost that was born by taxpayers
throughout the world
and so we see what happens when you have
privatized gains and socialized losses
and people will take tiny risks on their
own account all the time i mean
if we want to be you know hair splitting
about it we all take a tidy risk on our
own account whenever we hop in a car
you know it's like i really am hungry
and i want to go
and buy some popcorn and they've got
that great microwave popcorn
down at the safeway i'm famished i love
popcorn
i'm gonna go get it you're not thinking
i am putting my life on the line for
freaking popcorn but you are
it's a tiny risk and you take it um if
you dial that up there are people who
get involved at extreme sports
uh who take very very significant risks
in order to prove to themselves that
they're great in order to get
public accolades you know in some cases
some extreme sports probably have
nice tidy purses that can be made you
know nothing like you know in
professional basketball or football but
you know people on their own account
will take tiny risks and particularly i
think when you have somebody
who doesn't have deep family ties
doesn't have children
um you know who is you know earlier in
life or is more solitary in life or
whatever it is
they when they're facing that risk of
like i could annihilate the world
by mistake or make gazillions of dollars
and the risks of annihilating the world
are minuscule
their psychology because again we
weren't trained on the savannah to think
if i screw up
all humans die their psychology
is probably thinking very much in terms
of like i'm taking a tiny risk here
they're probably thinking about their
own risk of annihilation that probably
is
at least half of the calculus in their
mind because we're all
individuals and we don't want to die
they say that's minuscule
they might take the risk of a daredevil
you know the daredevil might take an
extreme sports person take like
okay i'm kind of putting it on the line
here but i think i can shoot these
rapids and
when lots and lots of people are in that
position you start arithmetically adding
up all those risks
and at some point it becomes untenable
so that's why the privatization is
really really dangerous
because it democratizes the technology
to the stage where
you include so many potential agents
that one of them
or multiple of them are going to be
outside of whatever overton window of
safety that we have
and they're going to lie there and
decide and this is just talking
about mistakes mistakes yeah this isn't
malignant
yeah this is negligence not malignant
negligence not malignant and i do worry
more about
worry more about malignants particularly
in synbio because
if we think about covid let's think
about covid
we've all been thinking about covert for
a while we're very practiced at thinking
about covet
if we think about covid it is remarkable
on a number of levels how benign this
this
horrific thing is um it
is not very lethal compared to a lot of
things out there it's not lethal at all
compared to sars
you know sars is you know depending on
what numbers we run
10 to 20 times more deadly it's also
coronavirus
uh mers middle east respiratory system
is
kills at a rate of about 30 case
fatality rate
um h5n1 flu which as you know i'm quite
grimly fascinated by kills about 60
60 of people and with covid case
fatality rate according to the world
health organization
somewhere between half a percent and one
percent so
covet could have been far far worse
merely on a
lethality basis and also on a
transmissibility contagious in spaces
if somebody were malignant if somebody
were were
were you know malicious and really
deliberately developing something to be
maximally destructive
it would be worse than kovit they lit
unless
an imaginable near future where somebody
is
sophisticated enough for the tools that
they're using are sophisticated enough
to allow them to basically dial that up
they're not going to unleash something
that kills a half a percent they're
going to
release something that is so much more
deadly and so much more dangerous
that it could have civilization toppling
potential here's something i've just
thought of
have you considered the potential that
the lab leak hypothesis
or some variant of it for covert 19
could be true
yeah and it's entirely plausible and
it's undeniable that it's possible at
this point
but that the reason that it was released
was some big picture thinking
fair weather saint human who said
bill gates has told you at the end of
his ted talk and we've been warning you
for years about the dangers of
engineered pandemics and natural
natural pandemics as well so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to give you
a very moderately transmissible but very
not lethal
pandemic which is going to act like a
global vaccine
it's going to cause you to have a very
benign dose
uh a coordination problem dose of how to
deal with this sort of a pandemic and
maybe this will make people wake up
we thought about that well have you read
somehow have you hacked into my computer
and read the outline
of a novel that i'm working on because i
i've actually
um that's a story that i've fleshed out
a great deal um so i'm
um familiar with them besides yeah i'm
familiar with it with
that scenario and it's a very very
interesting one and
i don't think that that was covet and
here's why i i think if somebody
wanted to unleash an engineered pandemic
to freak everybody out and and realize
how dangerous it was
they would make sure that the world knew
it was engineered
because you know right now the
prevailing wisdom in
science and policy making circles is
that this wasn't
engineered and therefore
the response has been more about
zoonotic like how do we prevent more
zoonotic transmission so if somebody
wanted to create
a mild engineered pandemic and freak out
the world
they would absolutely make sure that the
world knew this was engineered
so i don't think that's what happened
that doesn't rule out the lab leak
hypothesis they would have put like sort
your [ __ ] out world into the rna
yeah something like that where they
would have released some message online
or whatever it was
and you know done tried to do a pinprick
of salt and of course
uh a pinprick attack of some kind and of
course the danger with that is
that thing mutates and gets out of
control and annihilates us anyway
not that that's necessarily going to be
a plot twist in the book that i may or
may not write
but we've ruined it now all right so
yeah if
kovid was one of the more benign what
was
the most dangerous or lethal virus
in history that you've come across oh i
mean
you know probably one of the influenza
pandemics in probably 1918.
um i'm not saying covet is necessarily
but i mean like 1918 flu killed so many
more people
so many more people in a much smaller
world population
that proportionately it it's so much
worse than covet
and that we don't really know if that's
because we have better tools
and better detection and better public
health um
you know um practices today than they
had in 1918
that's possible or if 1918 was simply
much more virulent
my guess is it's a little bit of both
because it's not like we really
implemented amazing
best practices in public health and most
of the world
in australia new zealand did far better
than most of us
but um we kind of botched a lot of
things so
i'd say 1918 is probably worse but i'm
thinking more in terms of
you know again sars if you had sars
level lethality
and covet level transmissibility and
there's no reason that
that nature when it spins the roulette
wheel won't come up with that with a
nice big
incubation period as well probably where
you're still able to transmit yeah so
maybe
seven days 14 days without showing
symptoms
long grace asymptomatic period could be
catastrophic
you know measles think about
transmissibility
measles is unbelievable and
that you probably heard me say this
before in another conversation
but um basically the
the comparison as i know first of all i
think we all know at this point
that if we got into an elevator that
somebody with covet occupied
10 minutes before um and that elevator's
gone up and down the doors have opened
and shut people come in and out we go
into the elevator
like even five minutes after somebody
with covet was in there
and we're not wearing a mask the odds of
us catching cove in that elevator from
that person who was there five minutes
ago or
are essentially zero um that's the
understanding of the science today and
there's no reason to doubt that i mean
we learn more and more about code every
day but
that's that's pretty solid if you were
unvaccinated for measles or you didn't
have immunity
and somebody had been in an elevator
hours before
um you could catch it that's my
understanding and i've read that in a
couple of places and i'll
let just assume that snopes wouldn't
allow that to be
on the internet if it weren't true but
measles is
radically transmissible so the you know
the three dials to me are basically how
long is the person asymptomatic
how transmissible is it how deadly is it
and so there's a lot of dials that
nature has
actually hit without engineering the
high transmissibility measles
the towering lethality of h5n1 flu the
unbelievable
you know i don't know i don't know what
disease has a super long incubation
period
um oh tuberculosis um tuberculosis
people it usually is
um now this isn't necessarily incubation
but the time
from onset to detection is usually about
two years
and this is a storage month that we have
been fighting
forever right it's about two years
between when somebody starts getting
pulmonary respiratory tuberculosis and
when they get definitively diagnosed and
start going on drugs
um so yeah long incubation periods are
out there too
that's dangerous man and then when you
think that someone can play with that i
mean there's even an iphone game
right where you kind of design your own
pandemic it's been around for ages and
you should
see how it so maybe it's not just me and
you that are
that are obsessed with this talking
about some of the
leaks from labs that we've had this can
this is going back to negligence now
we've had some fairly close calls with
that we had anthrax
just after 9 11 ended up in the senate
majority leaders
office or something like that in an
envelope yeah an office that i had the
great fortune to pass through on the
very day that the envelope arrived
yeah i was in dc i had business at
tom daschle's office so yeah i was tom
daschle senate majority leader
uh this is a single digit number of days
after 9 11.
and so let's talk about lab leaks and
let's talk about
what happens when you've got a malicious
insider who
is leaking things and how hard that is
to prevent
so for those who don't remember this is
now getting to be a long time ago
immediately after 9 11 some envelopes
containing anthrax were delivered to
an a small number of places including
the office of tom daschle who was at the
time
of senate majority leader um patrick
leahy i think another senior senator
also democrat certain media outlets
including
the national enquirer it's just a
ghastly publication
so it was weird immediately the pattern
was strange
why would al qaeda and it was it was the
attempt and we'll talk about the attempt
in a second was made
to make this look like al-qaeda is
something why would al qaeda have a beef
with a national enquirer you know people
were a lot of people
were annoyed with the national enquirer
but they were generally annoyed with it
because it was kind of gutter celebrity
journalism with lots of paparazzi and
seemed to violate the privacy of lots of
people and seemed to dumb down the
readers and
there was a lot of sort of superior
sniffing on the part of
people who read the new york times about
those who read the national enquirer or
blah blah blah
i doubt that that was much of a
preoccupation of osama bin laden
um but there was weird scrawling on the
letters
that said you know something like
that the thing that immediately told me
that this is
this is somebody's faking it was like it
wrote
allah is great you know this is we're
doing this for allah
and arabic speakers even
who are learning english even ones with
very very very
remedial english very early in their
path of learning english
will quickly learn that the word for
allah
i studied arabic for years and years and
lived in the middle east for a long time
allah you say god so
god is great you know arabic speakers
who are learning english
and know enough english to write ransom
notes or you know
threatening things like that will have
learned probably in their first day of
instruction
that the word for allah in english is
god
they don't write hey i believe it's just
not done
it was just it was like a you know just
a remedial mistake
of a non-arabic speaker trying to
pretend
that they were an arabic speaker writing
english it was so flamingly obvious
so anyway these these envelopes go out
and
it eventually becomes clear that the
anthrax spores which were very deadly
um they were milled in away um that
they that the spores got into suspension
in the air
so respiratory transmission was far more
possible natural anthrax
is not neces it's hard for a
dust of anthrax to get go into
suspension in the air
in a way that can kill a lot of people
that's very careful middle
military grade processing or you know
you know in very sophisticated academics
that have to do that so it turned out
these anthrax spores
came from a us army lab probably at fort
detrick maryland almost certainly but it
might have been another army lab but
so let's think about that for a moment
you have the united
states immediately after 9 11. um
probably one of the most security minded
and security capable
nation states in the history of
geopolitics
you have the united states military
that has a lot of jobs but among its
jobs is to make sure the anthrax spores
in its own laboratories don't kill
anybody right
and so you know we can say all we want
about how inefficient
the united states military is at certain
times and you know make jokes about the
bureaucracy and so forth but it's a
pretty
security capable organization compared
to most places
and you have this nation and military on
absolute high alert yet it can't keep
the anthrax spores
from its own pocket from getting into
the office of the senate majority leader
who is one of the you know five-ish most
powerful people and most important
people in the united states government
that was one malicious party who had
access to that lab
and it's it's generally
considered that we know who it was the
person committed suicide before
they could go be indicted and go on
trial and so forth so
it was never proven in a court of law
but it seems pretty clear
who it was it was a disgruntled senior
person
who had no problem getting that stuff
out of that lab and getting it to the
senate majority leader's
office using the united states postal
service so
if that can leak when you have a
malicious actor from the
united states military after 9 11 high
alert everywhere
to somebody who i believe is in the line
of to succeed the president
you know the speaker of the house is i'm
not sure about majority leader that
tells us that any
lab can leak right you know if we can't
keep that out of a u.s military lab
after 9 11
what chance do we have of keeping it out
of a you know
mid-grade state university
bio lab if something equally lethal is
there
um so that's a malicious leak and and
what's dangerous about a malicious leak
is that almost all the bio safety
practices that are out there that govern
bio
bio labs are designed to present prevent
accidents
so there's four levels biosafety level
one two three four
and as you go up the chain the
precautions get greater and greater
to the point that biosafety level 4 labs
the highest
biosafety level that we have um you know
a lot of money and training goes in to
those precautions and
you know people are where there's
negative pressure suits and all kinds of
things that look
good on television um that go into
biosafety level four
i've heard biosafety level two is
something on the level of a dentist's
office
i'm not sure if that's a precise analogy
or you know or if that's accurate or not
but
you go biocephaly one two three four and
what we need to
realize that there have been leaks out
of biosafety level four laps
so the and accidental leaks and so the
probably
the one that most attention is drawn to
is
um foot and mouth sometimes called hoof
and mouth disease
um there had been a devastating outbreak
in the united kingdom
wiped out a very very high percentage a
very high percentage of the the cattle
herd
throughout the uk had to be called
billions in damages
so much like the united states against
any threat after 9 11
one hopes that the life sciences
infrastructure in the united kingdom is
on
very high alert when it comes to foot
and mouth disease in the immediate wake
of this outbreak
and not long after this outbreak foot
and mouth spores escaped from a bsl4 lab
in the uk
like they got out now they didn't start
another
they were contained they didn't start
another outbreak but that tells us bsl4
level labs can leak
by accident so certainly bsl123 can leak
and with a malicious actor i don't think
there's really any protection against
that
and so again like when we think about
do we want to do experiments for
instance that
could result in a civilization toppling
pathogen
you know let's say with the
transmissibility of covet and the and
the deadliness of h5n1 flu
that would probably topple civilization
we can get into why in a second but do
we want those
those spores or those viruses to exist
anywhere
uh even if it's people with the
brightest of white hats on doing it for
the best
possible reasons even government people
so it's not been privatized do we want
those spores or those viruses to exist
anywhere at all on planet earth the
answer has to be no
because if a malicious person ends up in
that lab and decides to go columbine
with that bio weapon or de facto bio
weapon
or if the lab has a boo-boo as labs have
all the time we're done
um so anyway a little bit of a riff but
yeah all labs leak
all labs at every biosafety level can
absolutely leak and particularly if we
get malicious actors in there than any
any lab can leak
so do we just glass ceiling how lethal
or how deadly
every person across the entire globe
every
sin bio researcher is able to get to
wouldn't it be nice if that were
in any way possible and unfortunately
it's not so
um what you can do you can do some
pretty simple and basic things
that significantly reduce risk so i'll
start with gain of function research
gain of function research is a branch of
research
it can mean a diversity of things and
nitpickers
um you know will say well you know it's
gain a function
when you create any gmo crop it's gain a
function
when you hone an antibiotic to be more
effective but
generally speaking when people in the
field use the term gain and function
they are referring to a narrow branch of
research which is one in which um
uh generally viruses but let's say any
deadly microorganism
um is tweaked in a way to make it much
more dangerous and deadly
and i'll use an example that is a very
powerful example in
many ways the most significant one that
we have um unless
we find out something about coronavirus
being gain of function research which
we'll get to in a second i'm sure
but in 2011 two independent teams one in
holland one in wisconsin
did gain a function research on h5n1 flu
which is the one that i mentioned before
that kills uh roughly 60 60
of the people in infects and um
it's it's rational to hate and fear h5n1
flu
but if you look at that little critter
there's one thing that we can all agree
is kind of adorable
about it which is that it's almost zero
transmissibility
you you need to really be in a
very very specific set of circumstances
that are unbelievably rare for any human
being in order to catch it
and there was a world health
organization survey that was done it was
a few years back
that documented each and every case of
h5n1 flu that led to death
and over the course of the decades
roughly 500 cases worldwide
and it's it's it's transmitted rarely
uh but very dangerously when it is
generally from poultry
to people who work in poultry farming
and it doesn't transmit from one person
to another
uh but if it did oh my god 60
fatality rate so what these researchers
did
is to oversimplify things but to cut to
the point
they made it transmissible through the
air um now they were working with
ferrets not human subjects um
but ferrets are a good model for virus
transmissibility in humans
which is why they're used in virus
research and so they both both of these
teams created an h5n1
that could be transmissible through the
air and
why because science you know
information wants to be discovered and
there was a great deal when these people
came under criticism and boy did they
come under criticism
there was a great deal of smug fist
waving of like
how dare you uh prevent science from
doing science
and the answer is because if this [ __ ]
got out
we could all be dead and the reason to
do gain and function research if you
talk to the virologists who do it and
there are quite a few of them
not just these two teams is like well
we're getting ahead of the game here
you know uh we're figuring out what
worst thing can happen so we can do
ingenious things to prevent it
um to which the response is um
there have probably been tens of
thousands of generations of homo sapiens
and influenza has probably been with us
the entire time
and not once has h5n1 become airborne
transmissible
so you're not exactly creating something
that is inevitably going to be dealt
from nature's dac in fact you're
creating something that probably never
will be dealt from nature's deck
and you're putting in it by the way both
of these projects were done
in biosafety level three labs not even
bsl4
so response number one is you're
creating stuff that probably would never
exist
otherwise and you're putting it into a
leaky vessel
which is a biosafety level anything lab
because science
okay and you don't get to do that you
don't get to take that chance okay you
want to take that chance with yourself
um you can get drunk and go skiing
and that's probably okayish
but if you get drunk and go driving
we're going to lock your ass up
and you can't say but driving how can
you interfere with my ability to drive
the open road the american dream like
no we don't we're that's not cool um so
that's a really good reason not to do
the other thing is
if h5n1 ever does become transmissible
god forbid
naturally there are countless
metabolic paths that it could take to
get there
there are countless peculiar sets of
mutations
that could happen it's not like there's
only one possible
genetic code that would create
transmissible h5n1 there are probably
you know countless different paths that
can be taken so it's not like this
critter that these two research labs
created
was something that we could then
immediately go and create a vaccine for
and say
we're done with h5n1 no
the peculiar version of h5n1 that
might arise naturally we can't
anticipate that
and so this research is unbelievably
dangerous
to the extent that it's useful i'm not
going to say it's completely useful
useless but
to the extent that it's useful it's
unbelievably limited
and the danger of a leak is profound so
after this work was done
both of these labs had papers teed up
one to go into science and one to go
into nature
which are the absolute pinnacle of
research science to get a paper in
either those are the two publications
out of thousands that one wants to be in
so oh my god they're going to get the
superstar treatment
and then the american government in
particular flexed its muscle
and i believe others did as well i think
maybe they did something in the uk and
holland as well but
basically uh science in nature we're
told you're not publishing that
and a great deal of you know concerned
thought uh ensued and there were
very very strange warnings issued by um
you know different sort of consultant
consultative bodies
that are that that think on behalf of
the us government but they're people
outside of the u.s government about
biorisk who really sounded the alarm
um but eventually and and funding for
gain of function research was eventually
paused
now that word paused um i didn't say
stopped
so for a period of several years in the
wake of all this in the wake of a couple
of
bio errors that the united states
government made i won't get into them
but there were like
a few blunders that happened that were
like kind of oh my god how did that
happen
that came to light it was after this
research and then after these
these sort of widely publicized blunders
the pause lasted
a handful of years that's it and the
pause
was in united states government funding
of
gain of function research there was
never a ban on it
a private actor could do it if they
wanted to um
governments other than the us government
could fund it if they wanted to there
was just a pause and both of these
projects the one in holland
and the one in wisconsin was getting
we're getting
nih funding national institutes of
health funding they were both getting
funded by the us government
so the government said okay we're not
going to fund this for a few years but
eventually those papers were released in
science and nature
and eventually that pause was lifted so
the us government is now funding gain to
function research
and those two projects got their funding
switched back on
those two very projects got the funding
switch back on i think
something like 15 months ago maybe a
little bit longer um
so the the world that said oh my god
this is scary
let's hit the pause button has since
said it's cool they hit the play button
and so gain a function research is
happening and it's
not irrational at all to think that gain
of function research
is happening with coronaviruses in
places where coronaviruses are
researched
no entity no national government no
you know major body of scientists is
saying thou shalt not do gain of
function research
it's considered to be fine right now
it's considered to be completely fine
given the potential dangers the expected
value of this
benefit versus cost i don't see it's
insane
i don't see how any scientist
that's able to do the complex level of
syn bio that you need to to probably be
able to
sequence these genomes and mess around
with the capability of microorganisms
if an idiot like me can understand
existential risk
why can't geniuses like them understand
the risk in what they're doing
again i think you've got a
semi-privatization issue even though
these people are getting public funding
so
let's try to inject ourselves into the
brain of you know the science
scientists in wisconsin um who decided
to go ahead with this research
in his mind he he i'm not saying he's a
bad guy he i'm
i i am sure his motivations are pure i'm
sure that he thinks what he's doing
matters and is helpful etc etc
but he's living in the bubble of his own
life in his own career
and he has the overconfidence that any
expert has in their own expertise
um i am an expert driver right
i've driven tens of thousands of miles i
have unbelievable confidence in my
driving ability and it's probably
misplaced
to some degree he is an expert wet lab
dude you know he's been running a
laboratory that has his name on it
that gets all kinds of funding from
different bodies and gets
grants from competitive sources and does
excellent work and has never had a leak
of any kind from his lap
so in his mind the risk of a leak
is negligible
he probably would not say non-existent
because they say it's so
low it's silly and also in his mind he
has got
you know utility function he has got you
know things that he's trying to maximize
in his life as all human beings do
and he wants his career to move forward
and he wants to publish in science and
nature
and he you know he wants to do all these
wonderful things
and so he is his own personal
risk reward um curve is out of whack
with the rest of humanity
if he does this gain of function
research and gets published in science
in nature
and does more gain and function research
and gets more celebrity and so forth
his career is going to be much much more
fun
and maybe not much more immunitative
because he's an academic scientist
he's probably capped out but it's the
things that motivate him
accolades papers that kind of thing are
going to come in in
greater greater and greater uh cadence
and so his utility curve says yes let's
go down this path
and he faces the same risk that you and
i face
if the world ends he dies now he's got
he'll have a lot of guilt maybe so maybe
slightly worse for him than you or i but
basically he says tiny risk i die very
high chance my career gets more awesome
and
i'm convinced i'm doing a good thing and
i'm convinced i'd never let anything
leak
just like rob reed has been driving for
decades he's never had an accident
i've been running a lab for decades i've
never had a leak so i'm never ever ever
going to have a leak right so he's got
misplaced confidence of any expert he
has got strong incentives to do things
that incur a tiny little risk but that
tiny little risk doesn't merely apply to
him it applies to all of us
and so the expected value curve that we
all run in our own brains
whenever we do anything is generally our
own interests
you know if i do this you know 10 chance
i lose this much money
um one percent chance i win this much
money 89 you know whatever we're
generally thinking for ourselves
he's thinking for himself but he's got
all of
us in the risk curve and he's not
calculating that expected value
of what happens if this goes wrong so
there's a bit of a privatization thing
there
even to go back to the first atomic bomb
test they did run the numbers
they did and even with the numbers in
front of them that there was a non-zero
risk
that the entire atmosphere could be
satellite
permanently curtailing not only all
human life but
everything literally obliterating the
atmosphere
and setting it turning the earth into
the sun briefly
and i think the number was
14 million one in 14 million
um i believe that um one of the
scientists put it actually a little bit
lower i think more like one in three
million
chance of that um but they didn't know
and that's that's the important thing
was non-zero now here's again we get to
the public-private decision
and this is really significant so at
that point um
everybody you know enrico fermi teller
all of these people at the very
beginning of the process
so 1941 as the manhattan project is just
getting going the first atmospheric test
is still years away
um i think it was it was either fermi or
teller
or oppenheimer one of them suddenly
realized oh my god
we could we don't know if we'd set the
atmosphere on fire or not
when we do the first explosion which
turned out to be four years later
and so it was immediately determined
that the odds of that were minuscule and
i think that a lot of the scientists
really said they're zero right but they
were running numbers up until the day
before
the very first test the trinity test
they were running numbers right up until
then and
they did the test and loan behold the
atmosphere didn't ignite now did they do
something irresponsible
well let's think about it um they did
take what they thought was an incredibly
low
but real chance of igniting the
atmosphere but particularly back in 1941
when they first confronted that danger
and decided to proceed down the path
anyway at that point
the most you know
the most facile nuclear brain power was
concentrated in germany at that point
and the only heavy water plant in the
world i think at that point
was in norway and germany and concord
norway it's 1941.
you're looking at a one in three million
risk that you might ignite the earth
and you're looking at a much higher risk
that hitler is going to develop a
nuclear weapon before you are
and we can all imagine what the world
would have looked like if hitler had
developed a nuclear weapon
first so that's
big real possibility this is also bigger
real possibility but minuscule and
ultimately the decision was made
at the highest level of you know a
flawed but
functioning democracy you know people
who had been
empowered by you know 100 million voters
or whatever the number of voters was
back in the 1940s probably less than
that
um but nonetheless a very very careful
public good you know it wasn't like
oppenheimer was going to be like oh my
god you know
103 million chance the atmospheric
knights you know
the remainder of chance ipo yeah it
could get published in science and
nature yeah
yeah i'm not going to publish the this
site not gonna go public and make a
billion dollars yeah
it was like he's facing the same risk as
all of us and he is thinking
on behalf of the planet they were
thinking very very very carefully about
that risk
and they ended up saying hitler with a
nuke versus this miniscule chance and
you know looking back on it um people
could argue both sides but that's the
point people could argue both sides
i'm really glad hitler didn't get a
nuclear weapon before you know his
enemies did
and you know was that risk worth taking
uh
you could certainly argue that it was
and i think that ultimately the
manhattan project people said
teeny tiny risk we need to win this war
you know let's go um and again i don't
think that that's
that could be debated eternally but the
fact that it could be debated tells us
it was not a crazy thing to do
whereas gain a function research i might
end up on science and i'm taking that
whole
like you getting on the cover of science
magazine
is not as awesome as beating hitler it
just isn't
beating hitler is really really good you
getting on the cover of science
doesn't matter to anybody in the frickin
planet but you
and taking a similar one in three
million risk let's say it's one in three
million risk
is is obscene when you're not taking
that risk to do something as
important for humanity as defeating
hitler
and we are going to be giving a lot of
people one in three million
roulette wheels we already have to me
bringing a virus
into existence that doesn't currently in
an effort to inoculate us
from the chance that it might come into
existence
it's stargraving mad thank you why
aren't we talking about putting bsl
three plus labs on the moon
yeah no okay so well this is this
actually started with when you say can
we do a glass ceiling and i was
starting out by saying well there's a
really simple thing we could do
but we're not doing it which is no gain
of function research
period at all the world should agree on
that just like the world agreed on you
know
nuclear non-proliferation and you know
other
there there have been treaties that you
know hundreds of nations have signed
over 100 nations of sign that's how we
got rid of chlorofluorocarbons
uh international agreement that we're
not going to use the stuff anymore
which more or less stock although there
are signs that they're being used in
china now um
on the sly but whatever um so we've done
this before
it it shouldn't be that hard for all the
nations of the world to agree
no freaking gain of function research
and that
probably stops it because there's
not much of there's no motivation for
somebody to for a private company to do
it
it really is academic it's generally
government funded it's generally done
in relatively transparent areas it's
generally done because people want to
get published
it's generally done or because the
government has an agenda
it would be an easy thing to say let's
stop all of that and now
you have taken one source of risk
out of the whole life sciences equation
of bio
error with gain of functions so that
should be freaking
easy thing for us to agree on but have
we
let's start there we're certainly not
there yet but if we do that
then there's a whole other set of risks
that are out there that like
okay we're gonna get better and better
and better at designing bugs in silico
we're designing bugs in lab because we
weren't smart enough to not do
gain a function or we're going to
continue to just publish
the genomes of things like the 1918 flu
and smallpox
and have that information out there like
we've got recipes for unbelievably
lethal things and instead of it being
you know something coming to be in a in
in a wet lab
and escaping we're not that far from
a time when people and this is
oversimplifying what they would do but
we're not that far from
a time when a lot of people in academic
and and private company settings
will be able to de facto hit a print
button
and get the genome of whatever arbitrary
equator they want
out and then have the tools to boot that
up and the mechan
in the mechanism of a virus and have it
start replicating and so
you gain a function is one lid that we
need to place
but we also need to really really harden
the entire syn bio
infrastructure to make it very very
difficult for people to
you know to print or obtain dangerous
dna
and there are quite respectable early
efforts
generally originating with private
industry
to limit the ability of any random
person
to get dangerous dna but they are not
wide enough spread
they do not have the force of law their
self-regulatory steps
that the biotech industry life sciences
industry has taken
and they're not really necessarily
envisioning
the day in which printable
highly distributed dna and rna synthesis
capabilities become widespread
and so that's another lid that we have
to put on that's a much trickier lid
than merely not doing something stupid
and dangerous
you know it's kind of like you know
imagine that you're raising a kid
who um loves to get drunk and drive
and uh also loves to go to school and
breathe
okay so your kid
stopping the gain of function research
is like
stopping the kid from drunk driving okay
we got that off the table
but he also goes to school and breathes
so there's a there's another risk that's
much more complex that he's going to
catch a deadly virus at school and you
know okay we've gotten rid of the drunk
driving
nice that's a good thing and stop doing
the self-destructive stuff
but now there's this much more diffuse
harder to define risk that we need to
work on
it's going to be difficult to survive
the next century isn't it it is
it really is
why aren't bsl three plus labs on the
moon on the moon
yeah well because most of the work that
they do
um is not with apocalyptic um i mean
these really truly apocalyptic micro
microorganisms
are rare and most of the work that they
do um isn't with things that deadly
um we don't have much stuff going on in
the moon right now so
chipping that stuff up there and
maintaining it up there and you know
all that payload and you know the tons
and tons of matter that need to be
transported from here to the moons
currently beyond our capability and you
know when you look at all the things the
good things that are being done
with therapeutics and you know academic
research that has an unambiguously good
agenda without
disastrous consequences you can
rationally say that like
the work that happens in bsl3 and bsl4
labs
is valuable to humanity it's largely
contained and
the danger of most of what's in there
getting out is highly highly local
and compared to what we're talking about
extremely minor
um so that's probably why we don't now
once we get to the moon we get to mars
and we're ferrying things back and forth
quite easily and naturally
perhaps another conversation should
happen at that point
but for now i think the easiest answer
is let's not have
any apocalyptic microbes anywhere um
and when we find you know
semi-apocalyptic microbes like the 1918
flu
let's not publish their genomes to the
internet you know that's getting rid of
the drunk driving
and yeah that's but yeah it's risky
it's risky as this stuff proliferates if
we don't build
really really great safeguards into the
tools before
they proliferate so given the fact that
we've had kovid
and this has been a coordination
inoculation if we want to call it that
that it's
taught us we aren't able to shut down
travel sufficiently quickly that we
weren't able to produce ppe sufficiently
quickly that
culturally given the technology of now
we didn't
have any archetypes for how people
should behave
that people didn't understand what
social distancing was people didn't
understand
why you should wear masks about what
staying at home and isolation was in
quarantine and
the way that we get vaccines out and
stuff like that um
do you feel like we're in oddly a better
position post covert
and if so how much yeah in in some ways
we are hypothetically in a better
position
if we take a set of actions in response
to covet to harden
society against the next pandemic if and
only if we take those steps
and so you know we ignored
the warning shots of sars and mers
and zika and a whole bunch of other
things you know we kept ignoring the
warning shots
kovid is a very very difficult warning
shot to miss
the whole world has been traumatized by
this um
trillions and trillions of dollars in
economic damage millions and millions of
lives lost
there will be much greater seriousness
applied to pandemic resistance in the
future the question is
will it be adequate attention and will
it be sustained
intention and will it be intelligent
attention and so
what there's a as as you know i'll
briefly plug another
appearance that i did um sam harris and
i did this
four hour piece that was a very unusual
podcast format in that
about a hundred minutes of that was a
monologue that i researched and wrote
and recorded
and i did the research i interviewed
over 20 scientists i read thousands and
thousands and thousands of pages
and in that episode i propose a set of
steps
that collectively are trivially
inexpensive compared
to the cost of even the annual cost of
the flu
let alone a true pandemic and i believe
if we take those steps and surely other
steps that i wasn't smart enough to
identify we will really
really really harden ourselves up i'll
use one example of something that
that we should be there should be a
global headlong
effort in right now and i've heard
absolutely no sign of that
um people who are deep in virology uh
are
are quite convinced that there's a very
high likelihood that with the right
amount of research in the right amount
of dollars we could create
pan-familial vaccines what do i mean by
that well coronavirus is a virus family
influenza is another there are untold
thousands of irish families but only a
few dozen
um present lethal risks to humans
coronavirus and influenza being two of
them
so let's say there's 20 of them it's
roughly 20. um we don't currently have
what we could call a universal flu
vaccine what a universal flu vaccine
would be or will be hopefully if we
develop one
is a vaccine that attacks the core
infrastructure of the entire influenza
family and so we have with the vaccines
that get issued every year
is there's lots and lots and lots of
mutations in influenza i mean
so many mutations it mutates
you know frenetically throughout the
year and when
we develop the vaccine for the northern
hemisphere we're looking at what's
brewing in the southern hemisphere
there's a lot of you know influenza
surveillance that's going on throughout
the world
and a panel of extraordinarily talented
scientists
make their best predictions of what
elements of influenza are going to be
predominant
let's say in the united states it's
probably the whole northern hemisphere
that gets the same vaccine but let's
just say in the united states to
simplify it
so i could be parochial as well because
here i am um
what what strains are likely to be
predominant
in the united states in in the coming
flu season
let's protect against that as best we
can in this year's vaccine
and some you know maybe 50 percent of
americans get
the flu vaccine probably less than that
some percentage of people be immunized
and in a good year that vaccine will be
about 60 effective
now a pan influenza you know a universal
flu vaccine
would say screw the strains we're going
for the jugular of this
it's called a species you know of
influenza
as a family um i talked to one person
who's very very deep in
um the world of lobbying for and doing
initial work for
a universal flu vaccine a guy named
harvey feinberg
used to run the harvard school of public
health um
like all kinds of titles and acolytes i
can't remember right now but he's he
estimated to me that
if we really went all in on this it
would probably cost about 200 million
dollars and take 10 years
to get there or not and he felt that
there was a 75 percent chance that we
would get there
not 100 chance i said harvey let's go
crazy
worst case scenario it could be 10x that
he's like
yeah he's like maybe it's 2 billion over
10 years and there's a
50 chance of getting there okay the
the flu cost the united states 365
billion dollars a year
in lost productivity and medical bills
if you have got a chance let's say
harvey's worst number
to invest two billion dollars with a 50
chance
of of relieving yourself of a annual
365 billion dollar burden
there should be no thought necessary at
all you take that chance and hopefully
harvey's right it's actually more like
200 million dollars and 75 percent
chance of success
what we should be doing right now is
let's take worst case numbers let's say
it's two billion dollars per virus
and there's 20 of them let's invest
those 40 billion dollars over the next
10 years
and get you know pan vaccines for
every virus that infects and kills
humans
and let's throw in another 20 the
zoonotic viruses that are out there that
are most threatening
let's get pan familial vaccines or do
our very best and at least have a 50 50
shot with each of them
you know 40 billion dollars over 10
years 4 billion dollars a year that's
that's
that's chump change in the context of
the american budget that's
chump change in the context of 365
billion dollars lost to flu
and you know one credible econ economist
um estimated 14 trillion dollars of
damage to the united states economy
us alone from coven but you you do that
i don't see that happening
anywhere there are a couple of academic
labs that are doing
uh working on a pan coronavirus vaccine
but they don't have a two billion dollar
budget this is not happening
and so when you ask me are we better off
for having had covid
theoretically yes theoretically we've
gotten a wake-up call that's unmissable
and now we're going to take really smart
preventative steps but this shriekingly
obvious step
you know there may be some governments
that are calling for it i can't read
every new story every day
i haven't detected any concerted effort
to say
let's just take every virus family off
the table that we can
and if we're not doing that and that's
really cheap and really obvious
um i could certainly see us not taking
a lot more more expensive and slightly
less obvious but equally important steps
after the last 15 18 months as well
yeah the most obvious flare fired up
into the air directly over our position
highlighting what the problem is
highlighting all of our insufficiencies
and uh poor coordination and yet
nothing yeah pan corona vaccine hello
people
why is that not happening now i mean
that research
search should have started in april of
2020.
what we don't have to wait for you know
the mrna vaccines and so you know that
research should have started
as soon as we said holy cow sars and now
this
coronavirus big deal but no that that
you know there is research like i said
i've seen a couple of papers coming at
academic labs harad go academic labs
but it doesn't have the public support
like the public funding support that it
needs
and that's yeah it's bonkers
what would be the implications if the
lab leak theory was proven to be true
for china
and for sort of the fallout
uh politically and the safety and future
as well
okay so let's um let's play this out
let's
assume for the the sa the sake of this
thought experiment
this was a lab leak um and it gets
proven definitively that it was
it would almost certainly be if this was
the case it would almost certainly
turn out that covet was a result of gain
of function research
uh because it is a novel virus and you
know it came out of nowhere
and if it was a lab leak it almost by
definition
would not have been something that was
circulating naturally and just didn't
happen to cause a pandemic
it would be something that was novel
that was created in that lab so i think
if that got out and was proven beyond a
reasonable doubt
there would one hopes that there would
be a global ban on gain of function
to start with like this bizarre thing
that we haven't done yet would be done
and i think banning gain of function
maybe eliminates
two to five percent of the total risk
that we face from
synbio run amok in evil hands or good
hands but that's a great step in the
right direction so i think that would
happen
um i think that you know we talked about
the compounding spread of
uh climate risk awareness i think there
would be an unbelievable jump
in global awareness and concern
uh about sin biorun amok and so i think
that
there would be a much better regulatory
apparatus there would be much more
self-knowledge
within academic and private circles like
a lot of really really good stuff would
happen is there a positive view that
hopes that it does get proven
well i mean if it if that's in fact
would happen all of me hopes that it
gets proven
you know if that's in fact what happened
um
yes absolutely uh china would have a
great deal to answer for
to every single country in the world
and you know china should be held
accountable
and the wuhan institute of virology
should be held accountable and the very
practice of gain of function should be
held accountable
and the notion that bsl4 lab labs are
safe should be held accountable
and so yeah if if that's in fact what
happened absolutely
that i would want that to come out so
that we
you know the world says china don't do
that anymore
the world says no more gain of function
the world says bsl4 is only a best
effort
and those three things right there uh
would significantly reduc reduce the
world's risk so yeah if that's what
happened i'd want it to come out
i think but we don't know we don't know
that that's what happened that we
probably never will well there's a lot
of opaqueness
right a lot of business incredible
opacity yeah incredible opacity which is
which what makes one suspicious but then
again authoritarian governments are
opaque by nature
it's their instinct it's almost like if
you could have picked
probably except for north korea if you
could have picked
a country that you didn't want it to
start in it would have been china yeah
in fact maybe
even more so that it's china because
they have more sophisticated resources
probably fewer bad actors that are
prepared to uh
turn mole and actually be whistleblower
about stuff better coordination
better surveillance
yeah i mean it's it's um the opacity
surrounding
the investigation of where this came
from is is
near almost total and you know it makes
one wonder
why what are we hiding you know and so
for those who and again i don't
i do not pretend to know whether it was
a lab league or not i want to be very
clear about that a lot of very very very
smart people
think it was a lot of very very smart
people think it wasn't so
and i don't have the level of
biosophistication to enter that debate
so i will
plainly state i don't have a theory on
that but a very strong argument in favor
of it is like
what in the world are you hiding because
you're hiding something
why in the world will you not allow you
know a very very serious outside
investigation
into the very early cases you know there
it seems that a couple wiv
went instantly to virology people were
hospitalized to something like an awful
lot like coveted in december
and you know why is that information
why is that not being explored you know
why did the world health organization
delegation that went there have zero
access to anything that
well to a lot that would have shed light
on the first five weeks
why all the opacity you know and it's
easy to imagine
something's being hidden it's but we
also have to acknowledge that
you know authoritarian governments are
opaque by nature that's their instinct
and they could be opaque for
reasons that are rational to them that
don't have to do with this
yeah yeah it could be that they that
that it's completely zoonotic completely
natural
and when they did their own
investigation they're like oh my god
our safety protocols at wuhan institute
of virology kind of suck
they didn't come out of there thank god
and feel really guilty if it did
but oh my god like it could have it
didn't but it could have
we don't want anybody seeing that it
could be something like that
the fallibility all the way down just
humans humans and our biases the whole
way
so zooming back out now from just sin
bio into
some of the broader strategies that we
have for x-risk
i think looking at all of the different
ways that we could potentially
manifest our own extinction on top of
the natural risks as well that are just
background and ambient and constantly
going on whether it be a super volcano
or a
gamma ray burst or an asteroid that's
going to come to hit us
um it seems like making the situation
already worse for ourselves is probably
a bad idea yeah
would there be an equivalent of reducing
uh putting a glass ceiling on gain of
function research or putting a glass
ceiling on the source
the sort of research that we do entirely
should we be looking at perhaps
considering that
across the board with regards to
technology should we curtail our
technological progress for a few
thousand years until our wisdom can
catch up with it
um i would say no for a diversity of
reasons
um one is i think it's thoroughly
impossible
it would it's it's strictly in the realm
of thought experiment
because if let's talk an entirely
equally impossible scenario but let's
say you know the western
democracies and eastern democracies you
know
the democracies of the world all agree
to do that
china ain't going to stop you know and
it just isn't
and if china stops russia's not going to
stop and if china and russia stop north
korea is not going to stop
and you know if north korea stops then
somebody that we never thought of like
you know uh
maybe suddenly you know egypt like
yeah who knows like if we all stopped it
you know and egypt didn't
a lot of smart egyptians they used to
live there at some point they're going
to be number one
in it and then being you know like you
just you know
there's a coordination problem and then
i also think that there's a human
flourishing problem as well it's
um sin bio has
so much extraordinary promise for us as
humans
it has so much extraordinary promise
when it comes to you know
therapeutics i think syn bio when cancer
is eventually beaten and if we don't
destroy ourselves
by some other mechanism one day we will
completely defeat cancer
and it's going to be insights and wisdom
that come out of synthetic biology and
adjacent fields
that do that it's going to be insights
and wisdom you know that come out of
synthetic biology and adjacent fields
that will allow us to eventually create
clean meat that is so much less damaging
to the planet
and so much less immoral in terms of the
horrible suffering that's inflicted on
the conscious systems that we call cows
and chickens
you know there's so much human and
non-human flourishing that's going to
result from it
that it's a path that we should go down
with lots of safeguards
and i just you know and if we wanted to
seize technology
we couldn't solve the coordination
problem and if we did
there's no guarantee that we would have
the wisdom that we seek in a few
thousand years
we've been trying to seek wisdom for
thousands of years already and
we haven't gotten there yet so the the
greeks and romans probably
would have thought if you asked them
like oh man 2000 years from now
we're so great at ethics already imagine
where we'll be in 2000 we must have
nearly finished we must be at the back
of the book
soon yeah yeah we got to be very close
to it except
of course almost all of those
philosophers owned slaves
so we can question their ethical purity
but that's a whole other conversation
so thinking about that if the global
coordination problem
is so tough that essentially this is
untenable it's not a strategy that we
can look at doing
you've got this increasing democratizing
or the privatizing of the apocalypse
you have the overton window of potential
bad actors
being uh more and more people being
brought in so that they're
perhaps outside of that we have
technology that is further emancipating
the ability to bring about our own
destruction right on an individual
on a local a national international
global level all of this
yep the
what are we doing the future doesn't
look bright yeah what do we do
when you take in this broad spectrum
view as opposed to just looking at syn
bio just looking at agi or nano
technology or
natural risk or whatever take a more
broad
scale perspective and i often think to
um super intelligence and machine
extrapolated volition with this
that trying to pick apart individual
strategies and tactics to try and
plug the holes in the bottom of the boat
one cork at a time
is is not tenable because that for every
cork that you put in there
a hundred that will appear far quicker
you can even notice that they're there
is this how you feel is this how i feel
apocalyptic no
so that what what i think you need to do
and so the the approach that i
i take when i think about sin bio is you
need to create a
really really agile adaptive and
multi-layered
uh defense strategy and i think great
inspiration
can be taken from our own immune systems
our own immune systems are confronted
daily
with all kinds of pathogens um many of
which they have never
our immune system hasn't encountered
before and
most people who are you know um
not extremely old and are well um don't
get sick most of the time
and that's because our immune system is
is is multi-layered and adaptive
very very adaptive and so to take
cinbaya as an example
um first of all you stop doing gain and
function research that's like i want to
live to be 90.
okay stop dr drunk driving every night
okay so great we've taken one thing
self-inflicted really obvious off the
table um
and that's like i said i think that
takes a few percentage points of risk
out of the equation
what i think would be very very big
would be
um something that the industry has
already tried to do on a self-regulatory
basis
which is to create a set of standards of
what is dangerous dna
and let's not let anybody get it unless
they have a very good reason to have it
so there's something called the igsc
which is a industry body
that a number of dna
makers are voluntary members of uh dna
makers what i mean by that
most of the complex dna and rna nucleic
acids
that are ordered or used in both private
and public settings
um generally are not made if it's if
it's a long
and complex strand that will generally
not be made in the lab that wants to do
the experiment
with it it will be made by an expert
body
a company and a good one example is
twist bioscience publicly traded company
they make a lot that's all they do is
make you know long strands of error
corrected
nucleic acid or that's a lot of what
they do so they're very good at that
they're better at that than any
particular
academic or private lab is likely to be
and so there's
several companies like probably number
the low dozens who do this for a living
and so those are the places where
dangerous nucleic acid is going to
originate for now um
a bunch of them are in this organization
called the igsc
and the igsc has maintains its main
product if you can call it that is a
database
of dangerous sequences and whenever
any igs member they've all agreed to do
this gets an order
for something that is on that list a
series of internal safeguards
go into effect and basically every order
is rated
red yellow or green vast majority are
green
nothing wrong with it no problem yellow
order comes in
and those companies have teams of
bioinformaticians
generally phds who look at that yellow
case and usually in most cases it's like
okay you know this is fine you know
they're taking part of
a gene that's dangerous but they're just
taking a regulatory part of the gene or
whatever it is it gets it gets passed
through
and when you get a red flag then a lot
of hours are spent and probably the
customers con
contacted and work is done to make sure
that
this is again benign usage and in the
worst case scenario these companies will
call the fbi
that's really good and the companies are
investing significant money in this
it's about my understanding talking as
few people it's about 15
per order of work that goes into this
whole if you if you take
the cost of all those bioinformaticians
and the red yellow green system inside a
company like twist bioscience
you total up that full budget and you
look at the number of budgets about 15
bucks in order
and you know there's real money these
are staffs of people that
this is great self-regulation but
there's problems with it
one problem is that as the ability to
synthesize
dna and rna um gets better and better
and and
cheaper and cheaper which is what's
happening has happened with computing
you're getting more and more orders
and the order size is shrinking and so
15 bucks is becoming a bigger and bigger
and bigger part of the order
cost um the cost of that apparatus
is significant enough that there are a
lot of companies that aren't members of
the igsc
for cost reasons and so the igsc says
that they account for 80 of the dna in
the world
uh or at least of in their industry of
provision uh but that number was kind of
pulled out of the air
a decade ago when the igsc was found
founded nobody really knows
and because there's only one chin only
one chinese member of the igsc
and there's a lot of dna synthesis going
on in china there's no way it's 80 right
so it it's it's a hell of a start it's a
very good start it's an admirable start
but we need to dial that game up
dramatically it
needs to be a hundred percent which
means that it it
it needs to be mandatory so voluntary
and 80 ain't going to work
got to be mandatory in 100 because if
you're a malign actor
it's really easy to go to the 20 who are
doing this like there's there is
essentially no protection unless there's
total protection
so if we could get this is a harder
agreement to get past
than a global agreement against gain of
function but if we can get past the
notion that like
we as a as a species are going to take
this igsc model dial it up and make it
mandatory
that's a big step forward now the next
step forward that is
very very important is that we are going
to go
to a distributed model of dna creation
what i mean by that
is you know the people twist bioscience
hate when i say this
um but i don't see there being
much of a role for central service
bureaus 10 to 15 years out
just as there isn't much of a role um
you know we all send a lot of text
messages today
um we send more text messages than at
any time in human history before
but despite our of our obsession with
text messages
there aren't a lot of telegraph
companies anymore right because
to send a text message in the 1920s you
had to use this very expensive
centralized
infrastructure to send your text message
and
we went to that centralized
infrastructure we sent our text message
and that's the way it worked
eventually that centralized
infrastructure disappears because that
capability goes out to the edge
it happened with photography that's
happened with a lot of recording tech
this happened
countless times it's just what happens
and so
bench top dna synthetic synthesizers are
in their infancy right now
but there's a pretty good one out there
now called the the bio xp
which allows scientists to synthesize
the dna that they want
in their own dam lab without being
wizards because the scientists are using
the dna they don't want to be great at
synthesizing dna they're synthesizing it
for a purpose
they want to get that synthesis that
synthesizing out of the way as quickly
as possible
to do their actual work synthesizing the
dna is like brushing and flossing their
teeth it's
you got to do it but it's not you don't
wake up saying today i'm going to brush
and cloth my teeth
going to be the pinnacle of my day they
want as little hassle as possible that's
why they're using twist bioscience
rather than developing those
capabilities themselves
and if there's a little machine that
they can have in their in their
lab and just print out what they need
that's going to be even better than
twist bioscience much as
the iphone is better than a telegraph
office so the next thing that we need to
do as a species as a global society is
say
yes those distributed printers are
coming they need to be mini igsc's
they need to have those protocols built
into them so that dangerous dna
also goes through this process and the
makers of the the bio xp which is the
best printer on the market right now
they are an igsc member and when you're
printing something on your bio xp that
print desire goes back to the company
that makes the printer
and it goes to the red green yellow
process and so
that's a doable step now let's imagine a
world 20 years from now
where these printers are everywhere even
in high schools and they've got these
very very good protections and
safeguards in place
does that mean it's impossible to create
a doomsday bug
certainly not it's still possible but
what we've done
is we've made it so much harder
that the number of people who can pull
it off has gone from
you know untold you know hundreds of
thousands even millions
to a tiny handful of experts that's an
unbelievably powerful protective step
because
you know particularly that tiny narrow
group of experts that would we'd prefer
to be zero
but those people have generally come
through life
following a path of continuous
self-improvement career development
they're not
the type of people in general they're
not the type of people who go columbine
anthrax leak not withstanding they're
generally not so you've diminished a
great deal of risk and also with the
passage of more time
the ability to create a complex virus
genome from whole cloth
will even vanish from the high pinnacles
of academic science
because it's just not necessary anymore
there was an incident a few years ago
where a canadian researcher
created the horse pox virus that genome
from from whole cloth um horse pox is
not a big deal
to humans um but what's interesting and
important about it is it's a very close
cousin to smallpox
and so if that particular academic
scientist in canada
was able to synthesize the horsepower
virus using male order dna and other
techniques and his own
extraordinary you know skills um
that means by definition he could have
synthesized smallpox if he wanted to
he just elected to synthesize the
equally complex
horse pox and very closely with horsebox
fires and part of the reason he did that
was to put the world on notice hey this
is possible
and some idiot put the smallpox genome
on the internet
back before this was possible and hello
world wake up
right now the skills that he has to
create
that are going to they're not going to
become more and more widespread as as
printers and things like twist
bioscience get better and better
they're actually going to diminish
because those sort of wet lab skills
create things from whole cloth and so
forth people aren't going to develop
those skills because they're just going
to be able to hit print
so if the world if if the academic world
and the life science and sinbio world
become dependent
on these distributed printers which i
believe they will um
and the printers are really really good
at preventing bad stuff from happening
now that's a pretty big protective step
so you're actually utilizing humans
inherent laziness
or their paths of least resistance to
distract them with that
i mean the sequence that you went
through with sam that four hour
special is one of the it's an absolute
masterpiece
and thank you the work that you guys did
on that is phenomenal it'll be linked in
the show notes below for anyone that
wants to do a deeper dive
on this i want to change tack for a
second have you read
seven eves by neil stevenson
seven eaves is the one where the moon
explodes yeah it's the first line the
first line yeah
yeah yeah the moon explodes okay i'm
really embarrassed and i hope neil's not
listening because
we've been a few times and i think very
very highly of him but
i love neil and his writing that was one
i couldn't get through
and the reason was um sometimes
i think you know it neil's work turns
into mechanical engineering porn
and um i am not very adept when it comes
to mechanical engineering and it's not a
fascination of mine unlike
bioengineering and other things i'm
obviously not a life science expert
either but
that'll get through but like there's a
lot of like this device is this and
there's this gear that has this leverage
ratio and that's really cool because
this
and so i was like i just can't but it
was a hell of a start i'll tell you i
really enjoyed the first 50 pages
yeah so i and i have i have i have
that's the only neil stevenson
novel i have ever started and not gotten
through that's crazy
so yeah yeah it's it's a i wouldn't say
it's a slog but there's a certain thing
i mean you learn
the uh finer points of orbital dynamics
right in this you're learning about the
nazi
and all of the different ways that the
front and back of a three
uh three-dimensional boat essentially
which is what a spaceship is moves and
how when you swing back around you're in
different positions so yeah hard sci-fi
can be hard
at some times um but everyone that's
listening it's in the new
uh reading list which is about to get
released which everyone can pick up for
free quite soon
uh but in it this thing occurs and they
need to find
somewhere to get people off earth right
they need to put them up into space
it's the equivalent of an existential
risk there is an existential risk the
fact that
the moon exploding is irrelevant it's
something the difference is that they
have
almost exactly two years from when it
happens to when the
what they call the white sky or the hard
rain begins
and um what they actually do is they say
at the very very beginning the president
says we need to
have a two-pronged strategy we need to
send people underground
and we need to send people into the sky
given the fact that we are constantly up
against an increasing
anthropogenic risk from ourselves an
ambient background natural
risk we don't have a second community on
mars
we don't have another planet we do not
have a backup would it be advisable
to create a siloed community somewhere
which is totally self-sufficient
defended and
air-gapped from the rest of the world i
have
never thought of that and shave on me
because that's such a cool idea
that anybody who thinks about
existential risk should be thinking
about this
that is a really freaking interesting
notion
um wow yeah we should
we should have that you know the long
now foundation
uh has uh this really cool
library they've created which has the
you know 1500 books
that they believe would be necessary to
reboot civilization
and they've got if you go to the
interval cafe
in the fort mason area of san francisco
and anybody going to san francisco i
urge you to go to the interval cafe it's
awesome it's run by the lung now
and downstairs is the cafe and bar and
upstairs are all those books
they've got this library but you can't
go up and look at them there's a you
know unless you know somebody from long
now he's going to take you up there but
that's almost a symbolic gesture
and you know yeah i mean creating a
community like that and maybe it's like
national service like you rotate through
for two years like nobody would want to
live their entire life there but
you know maybe it's you know a whole
bunch of young people because you want a
lot of young people you can
you know procreate and all that other
stuff but maybe it's like a
you know people go on a two-year
rotation which would probably be kind of
fun and cool like a neat thing to have
done for two years
to be in that community it seems dumb to
me that we're waiting
for some sort of potential risk to occur
before we can save ourselves from it
like i know that i know that the problem
is fully air gapping yourself whilst
you're attached to the same piece of
rock is going to be difficult if you've
got a malignant ai that's got a control
problem that's running around
it'll probably know where it is it might
be able to manipulate it
but again the same thing as you're
trying to achieve with the sin
biosolutions it's not about
perfect it's about reducing the risk as
much as you can because that's all that
you can do just because you can't get
perfect doesn't mean that you shouldn't
try
so for me defended you know really
heavily defended
walled off somewhere in a mountain
bunker [ __ ]
you know all of the seeds all of the
books all of the
everything that you need and just if
you've got it there yeah ethically is
there a question yeah of course there is
it's the same as the generation ship
arguing you know if you're going to fly
to alpha centauri and decide to commit
the next thousand generations of your
progeny
to living on them yeah exactly to be
born live and die
in in this steel cage floating through
space is that
ethical well if you decide to take the
grandest view of humanity as a whole if
the choice is between
some people suffering and humanity dying
i think that
that so this is something i reckon more
people
should be considering that because
there's bunkers isn't there um
have you looked into these rumors that
billionaires are buying up is it new
zealand or australia that they're buying
up
ranches or bunkers or something have you
heard about this yeah
there's well the whole prepper movement
is very real preppers this is preppers
on steroids
and this is some and some preppers would
be billionaires and they're gonna
yeah so i'm sure that there's some crazy
prepping stuff going on
um what's what's more relevant to this
conversation there was
a big effort in the very early 90s
called i think was biosphere 2.
have you heard about this no so as some
some
um you know kind of eccentric
billionaire or near billionaire funded
another
eccentric stream to create a completely
independent biosphere
and it was in somewhere in the
southwestern united states like
arizona new mexico something like that
and the bones of it still exist
and it got a great deal of press at the
time and so they
created this huge bubbled community
and it was the bubble was huge the the
physical footprint was huge the budget
was huge it was privately funded the
number of people was not
it was something like 9 or 11 people
went in there
and the objective was to completely
decouple from the earth's biosphere and
it wasn't bunkered it wasn't
guarded it was you know but just
decoupled like an ecological rather than
a defensive
uh experiment yeah yeah and uh
you know have agriculture going on in
there and you know have all these
you know to try to create a biosphere
and balance that these people could
live in and be completely
self-sufficient in for two years
and it failed and there's a really
good documentary that i saw toward the
beginning of covid that i i'm happy to
try to dig up and you could put it in
the show notes
it was well done um it failed for a
bunch of reasons
but basically the agriculture started
failing um
their ability to generate enough
calories in there you know was meant to
you know they had huge huge greenhouses
and so forth
that started failing and then also the
carbon in the atmosphere the internal
atmosphere started getting out
out of whack and so at some point this
small group of people
were slowly starving and asphyxiating
and they eventually gave up
and there was also this controversy
where one of the people needed to have
surgery and so obviously left the
biosphere
to get the surgery she needed and came
back in
laden with like a santa claus like bag
full of stuff that
that was missing so people like oh you
guys are cheating
but you know okay this did not have the
budget or
scientific power of even a lightweight
government effort i mean
when you when you watch the documentary
you realize kind of how
absurd it was like a don quixote type of
thing it was charming but a little
absurd
and they just didn't have the fire power
to pull this thing off um
but that's an interesting relevant
example but i think what you're
describing
would you know it could be a national
effort the u.s has the
the resources and budget to do it and
china does and a couple other places but
you know
maybe ideally it'd be international and
you wouldn't be sentencing people to
life for thousands of generations of
life
i imagine people would rotate in and out
and i imagine rotating in would be a
pretty cool experience to have in life
if you were there for a year or two
there'd probably be lots of other young
single people in there it'd probably be
kind of fun
you know there's people who spend the
winter in antarctica you know if you're
in antarctica at one of the research
stations
um once winter settles in there's nine
months you cannot get out
and that's a small group of people and
it's really intense and a lot of people
have horrifying experiences but some
people have awesome experiences with
that
you know so yeah they're gonna be kind
of like that that's a really interesting
idea
i like it cool what do you think is a
big x-risk which is rarely talked about
within the community
so you might not be able to predict the
unknown unknowns but what about the
barely known unknowns or the recently
known unknowns
well you know there is there was an
experiment run at cern
on brookhaven back in the 90s
that the best documentation i've seen of
it is in martin reese's book
our final hour and that's what's called
the united states and it's got the much
more intelligent title in the uk
of our final century so i guess the that
sort of reflects the perceived attention
spans
of the american and british populations
according to the publishers who released
that book but it's an amazing
book it was one of the first really
um popularly accessible contemplations
on
on x-risks um and it really was
more about like things that could wipe
out he was also very interested in
things that could wipe out tens of
millions of people
but there was this experiment run that
had
a tiny chance uh again let's talk about
trinity experiment in new mexico
level chance of creating something
called a strangelet a hypothetical form
of matter
which is very much like ice9 in cat's
cradle by kurt vonnegut
so cat's cradle is a brilliant novel
that i'd recommend to anybody who enjoys
speculative witty crazy fiction
um and i in cat's cradle there was this
thing called ice9 that somebody
developed
that if it touched it is a form of ice
that if it touched
water the adjacent molecules would also
turn ice9
basically at a melting temperature of i
don't know 90 degrees
fahrenheit you know 35 40 degrees
centigrade and the
the danger with ice 9 was if it touched
normal water
the adjacent molecules would immediately
turn into ice nine
and the adjacent molecules to those
would turn into ice
touch yeah it was like minus touch
almost instantly any water it touched
would turn into ice night and would only
be meltable if you got it
really hot and so this is a taking time
bomb
that runs throughout the novel because
obviously
if somebody drops a shard of ice nine
into the ocean or even into
a tributary a minuscule tributary of a
minuscule river
that is going to flow through the all
the water the earth with an unbelievable
rapidity and game over
so strangely decide and if it exists
if it exists and if it has if it's
possible to exist and if it has certain
properties and
if if and they if it hit this down at
the sternum brick heavy
institute um experiment to say oh it's
just really unlikely
and they proceeded with the experiment
and
if the strange lit thing had happened it
would have turned
all of earth into strange lit matter and
it's unlikely but possible that the ice9
effect would have propagated further out
and might have destroyed the entire
universe
[Laughter]
that's not the reaction that humans need
to have to existential risks in order to
prevent it if we think existential risk
is just
excellent forms of comedy we're done
chris
no but it's so interesting it's so
interesting so
i'm so fascinated by it once again we
probably have
a set of risk and payoff in the minds of
the scientists who are making this
decision like
that's just really unlikely and if it
doesn't happen and it almost certainly
won't
might end up on the cover of nature
might end up on the cover of science
and there was no so they went ahead with
it and the danger with that is only this
cloistered elite is in a position
to say no because only this cloistered
elite is in a position even though the
experiments happening
and to know its ramifications and some
outsider came in and said no
don't do it they'd be like okay
nincompoop uh what did you get your phd
yeah exactly oh exactly you studied
arabic in college and now you're a
government regulator
well you're too stupid to even under
understand the risks that we're taking
blah blah blah and
yeah yeah so it's things like that you
know it's
it very few people know about that that
being said and this is where i want to
pivot into something that i'm quite
passionate about with regards to
x-risk and this is what i see as the
future of humanity institute which is
phenomenal and the work that nick and
toby and the guys do there is
outstanding it's world changing um but
what i see
as one of the big holes in their um
world view with regards to trying to
enact the most successful
existential risk um protection
strategies is a lack of an understanding
of the importance of public idols so
if you were to look to someone like
greta thumburg
not a climate scientist not a specialist
in her field
and yet because she was right place
right time right delivery
she was able to garner support behind a
particular movement
and what i think is missing and what
you've just highlighted there the fact
that there aren't sufficient people
if you had a million people that had
phds in arabic
and were wagging their finger at
somebody you'd go
actually there's a there's quite a lot
of people outside of the office maybe we
have to listen to them
but when you have small number of people
and the type
of research that's being done is very
specialized and gated within these
particular intellectual communities
the intellectual proletariat are not
going to listen to the plebs in the
street
especially if there's only three pl me
me and you and sam harris like waving
our hands outside like that's not going
to work
so i think that there needs to be a
i think existential risk research and
the movement at large needs to be made
more sexy and more popular that's not to
say that the guys
at the you know nick and toby are
handsome gentlemen but someone who's
going to be out there you know anders
sandberg is a perfect example of this
although he's busy doing
real research and actually getting the
work done
but more of these sort of public facing
talking points the stuff that the things
that you did with sam
um josh clark the end of the world with
josh clarke was
and podcast series yes design part
podcast series
fully soundscape oh beyond outstanding
but it needs to be like endless amounts
of that get people interested
because the compulsion that i have and
you have we're not outliers like this is
something that a lot of people would
just naturally be interested
in and then on top of that when you say
this is potentially the most important
thing that any of us can work on
at all in our lives the most important
thing the
successful continuation of the human
species
or the ensuring that we do not neuter
permanently new to our own ability to
reach our full civilizational potential
is
what else is there like other than
enjoying your life and you know loving
the people that are around you and stuff
like that
as far as callings go i can't see much
that is bigger than that
so there seems to be a delta between the
fact that it's so compelling
and and so important and naturally
interesting to some of us
and also there is this huge vacuum when
it comes to the public conversation
about it
and the pressure that's being placed on
artificial intelligence research and
nanotechnology and sin bio and have we
got
the the first time that you a person who
is steeped in this world and has written
novels about it
has heard and there should be no way
that there should be any idea that
hasn't been heard already
when the consequence is the outcome of
our species yeah and the other thing
that we could use
more of is storytellers and so as a
science fiction writer that's something
that i can
do a bit of and you know i believe that
a very significant reason
why we survived the cold war as a
species was movies
like war games in movies like dr
strangelove
that really really resonated with the
popular consciousness
and really got people freaked out
at all levels of society those stories
can travel in a really really powerful
way
um i think one reason why the world
dodged the bullet of totalitarianism um
in you know that the the resistance of
totalitarianism
like really methodical resistance to
totalitarianism you could date it you
know to world war
kind of can't really date it to world
war ii because we're fighting alongside
stalin against hitler right
um it really kind of dates to the 1950s
you know if you look at the intellectual
landscape in
i don't know about all countries but
certainly in the united states in the
30s and 40s and early 50s
it was unbelievably fashionable
to lionize communism it was unbelievably
fashionable
to lionize stalinism and lots and lots
of thoughtful caring
people really really smart people um
became communists and not merely
communists but a lot of them would have
done anything
to hasten a communist revolution in
you know in western democracies
yeah bring on a salonistic government
what changed all of that well a lot of
things did
but i think a very big thing that
changed all that was the novel 1984.
1984 was written in 1948 and it was a
monster global sensation and
the intelligentsia like all novels it
was read more by the intelligentsia than
by the extreme mainstream but that
really shifted the dialogue of the
intelligentsia
it painted such a plausible and
horrifying picture of what stalinism
with slightly better technology would
look like and it was a science fiction
novel people forget that
1984 was a freaking science fiction
novel first of all it was set in the
future people
and secondly the telescreen technology
that the thought police used to keep an
eye on everybody
that was impossible in 1948 so it was it
was near future sci-fi
and it was it shifted
the debate anybody who read that book
could no longer say
i want to live under stalin you just
couldn't it really inoculated
the western democracies or you know free
countries throughout the world i keep
saying western nation
um it really inoculated
most of the intelligentsia and it really
inoculated
most of the free world against the lure
of totalitarianism what was the allure
of
totalitarianism go back a couple decades
in the 1930s the world's going through
the great depression
and you know all you see are heavily
stalin was
was industrializing a non-industrial
nation of
the soviet union at an unbelievable pace
and there was a lot of low-hanging fruit
that kind of worked in the 30s and 40s
and you have a lot of people who are
worried about starvation
in you know outs outside of the
communist block and says get seductive
and it gets seductive if you're you know
a brilliant student at cambridge or
harvard or whatever and you encounter
these ideas and they're all about
you know the good of the many and so
forth and that inoculation was really
powerful from 1984 and so i think we
need
stories um more stories like the
terminator people chuckle and sneer and
snigger about how unsophisticated the
terminator is
but guess what it brought the notion
of super ai risk to basically everybody
understands
the terminator story in skynet you know
i mean some people are
not are so disconnected from popular
culture they don't but
you have much less if you want to talk
about super ai risk to somebody who's
not
inculcated in the world you have a much
shorter path to that
to getting them up to speed and
understanding the risk
because we've all seen terminator that
was pretty damn good story
we haven't really had the symbiote
terminator franchise yet that would be
really useful
have you been really really useful have
you seen next
i think it's an nbc series no
okay tell me about next sorry excited
next is a nine or ten part series
about a misaligned super intelligent
artificial general intelligence
that goes rogue and starts taking over
the world but it's done
in a very very smart way so the guys
they're using the language of nick
they're talking about recursive
self-improvement
it's trying to find it's trying to find
the correct architecture
with which it can deploy itself onto
multiple servers because it knows it's
got the algos but it doesn't have the
computing power to be able to do it
it's trying to manipulate people
psychologically it's trying to
manipulate people with regards to their
logistics it uses different
actors to play off against each other it
knows it is
phenomenal um and it's it's a bit
for whatever better term it's a bit
americanized right it's very dramatized
it's sort of glitzy and everyone's got
really nice teeth and so on and so forth
and there's a kind of an elon musk type
character in there who's a little bit
crazy and he's trying to fix things and
but next uh anyone that's been
interested in this if you want to watch
it
like a 10 part series i think it's nbc
um it's fox i just [ __ ] i'm looking at
the wiki
wikipedia page right now it sounds
fabulous it's legit and they know
they know their stuff they understand
about the alignment problem they
understand about
recursive self-improvement and and what
it would try and do
again there's some dramatization but
that again you're right i think pushing
the culture
in that sort of a way so i came across
this this quote
and it was um someone
criticizing the uh intellectual
commentary out of the
uh intelligentsia and saying just
because you've beaten bad philosophy
doesn't mean you've beaten bad
psychology and what they were
highlighting was the fact that people
who can
um proselytize about
ideas academically are still
at the mercy of cognitive biases because
they're still human
deep at heart and i think that what
you've just hit upon there uses the same
it leverages the same type of mechanism
right so if you can move the culture in
a way where it becomes desirable to have
a particular
mode of thinking because all of the
norms have been pushed in a particular
direction through
things that people don't even consider
like how much
did those movies to do with the cold war
in the late 1900s how much did that
really push public consciousness
or how much did the terminator really
open people's eyes to the fact that oh
my god like this is
this is what super computers perhaps
could do and that was well well
well before its time so long ago yes so
prophetic yes unbelievably profound um
the same thing that happened with 1984
you can shift culture not just through
academia but through entertainment
as well not just through education oh
yeah absolutely no i don't think
entertainment is an enormous lever um
yeah
it shapes culture in that way so yeah i
think yeah i think that would be a uh
a very useful way to do it so let's say
that someone's taken the
existential risk black pill perhaps
we've begun
some people at the beginning of their
domino's sort of toppling journey today
or there might be some people that have
joined us
who are already part way up the mountain
or down the mountain depending on how
you look at
it how would you advise them if they're
passionate about this topic
generally general existential risk how
do you think that
we should conduct our lives to
contribute best to a cause that we care
about
wow that is an interesting question i
mean i think
you know people who like the relatively
few avenues right now i mean they could
contribute money to the few centers
that are working on this i mean that's
something that anybody could do with
five bucks
and if millions of people do that with
five bucks then the budgets that support
people who think about this full-time
would rapidly rapidly expand um i think
that you know
public pressure on governments
everywhere
to take this seriously it would be
pretty highly leveraged outcome i mean
let's imagine
that you know the united states and
australia
continue to hit the snooze button on
this whatever but
for whatever reason denmark gets with
the program
okay the danish government is very small
compared to the us government
but it's very very very large compared
to most organizations in the world
you know a mid-sized country with lots
of resources lots and lots of brilliant
people
you know very progressive social
policies if the danish government said
you know what
we're going to try to lead the world in
taking this series
seriously and then they started
directing government-sized budgets
as opposed to academic-sized budgets at
the problem you know
any government of mid-size or greater
that decided to make this a priority and
fund a lot of
basic science and and public education
and so forth
that would really be a major domino to
fall
so i think people even particularly
people in countries like denmark
or estonia you know that are smaller
countries that
you know have maybe you know a higher
average iq than my country i don't know
like you know
but small well-organized countries that
have a history
of you know being a little bit ahead of
the curve when it comes to social
policies and other things
um any government that takes this
seriously and uses the might
of government and the megaphone of
government could have
would have a significant impact on on
public awareness
um it just that would be a hell of a
start
so you're talking lobbying local
officials
bringing it up more i suppose the
problem is
again the chasm between most people
when you talk to them about existential
risk it's just not
the same way as 100 years ago climate
change wouldn't have been a word
so i suppose that's something that's
definitely something i'll take away from
this conversation i think i'd looked at
existential risk and the furthering of
existential risk as a purely academic or
intellectual
um conversation which then needed to
essentially just be communicated
to people through shows like this or
youtube videos that are kind of like
edutainable or whatever it's called um
but
the cultural side of that you know
moving people in pure entertainment
uh is something that i totally didn't
consider but it's probably
even more powerful and and more
accessible
yeah it's part it's part of the the the
packet of things you want to do
um what was the name of the guy who
created the uh podcast we were just
talking about into the world podcast
which was
what josh okay so let's talk about
really local government now
so let's say somebody is influential
with their local school board
and they say we're going to do something
crazy here we are going to
in our school system have a required
10-week course
for all seniors all you know all people
who are about to graduate
to be fun class but it's a 10-week class
they all got to take and they're going
to listen listen to
josh's podcast and there's going to be a
smart you know
social studies teacher who leads it
they're going to have great discussions
and debates
and you know we're going to just do that
in our school system because that's what
we can influence
and then maybe some state or provincial
government says
hey this is cool it starts spreading
like again it's like compound spreading
and so nobody was aware of existential
risk 15 years ago really
now i think low digit millions of people
are aware and interested in the subject
and at some point you know maybe one of
those people is the chairman of a school
board
and implements this and so you suddenly
have a local school system studying this
and maybe adjacent towns say that's a
neat
and you know this is the compounding of
it or
people who did that high school class
nine years later one of them's in a
position of influence that's how the
environmental movement over the 50 years
people became aware through this or that
and they made more people aware so i
think that you know anybody who can
implement some kind of policy whether
it's local government school board
national government
to take this more seriously that's
that's a big step oh here comes ringo
oh yeah at least popped up on the
hasn't gotten into the camera yet but
he's in imminent danger
i've got to just lift him up
what a way to it looks very placid he is
right now but i think he's telling me
that he wants to go out and
i'm going to obey that signal because
you know that means something with a dog
he
doesn't want to make a mess ringo is new
to potty training i've had him for
a month he's a little rescue dog he's 12
months old and he came to me
unpotty trained and he's learned very
quickly but well no i think he's just
saying he wants to cuddle
okay we may not have to go out
oh he's barking at somebody in an
adjacent deck
anyway well we got ringo now
now you're not going out if you're going
to bark dude
anyway i'll deal with ringo i think
we're good right now cool uh
rob reed ladies and gentlemen rob thank
you
so much for coming on today this has
been everything that i wanted to try and
get out of it but there's still
yet more to talk about so round two may
have to happen in the future
i'd be very open to that it's been great
to be here it's been so much fun talking
yeah
talk to me about what we can expect what
people can expect from you coming up
you're working on books and have you got
any other
super secret projects that you can tell
hint at
uh so i'm working uh there's a
pretty serious effort that's pretty far
along but about to
hit one of the really you know um
significant you know go no-go decisions
to turn one of my novels
into a movie that i've been very engaged
in and
if that happens um there's some prospect
that i would be
involved in you know the the further
creation because it'd be a
feature-length animation
um which is something that happens over
a period of years rather than 10 weeks
of production and so that's a cool thing
that i've been working on
um my podcast is called the after on
podcast it's not unlike yours it's yours
is more similar to my podcast than
anything i can think of really
and i interview you know world-class
thinkers and scientists and
occasionally entrepreneurs um about
their life's work and
and try to you know create an interview
that makes all that really accessible
um i had a long hiatus from that because
i was doing a bunch of other projects
including this thing with sam
but that's now up and running um so i've
got new episodes coming out with that
um i've been very busy recently
uh writing and recording a lot of music
with a band called the god children
hello ringo
ringo is not our drummer ringer's a
drummer in another van not this ringo
with a band called the god children we
are invisible online as of yet but we've
got a bunch of music that we're about to
start releasing which i'm pretty excited
about
and the thing that's been taking up a
great deal of time recently
is i started an investing partnership uh
with a guy named chris anderson who runs
and uh for all intents and purposes kind
of owns
and he bought the ted conference he's a
ted conference guy
and he bought the ted conference which
was a profit making concern and put it
into
a non-profit um entity so it
nobody owns it now but he's the one who
bought it he sky runs it so he and i
have created an investing partnership
we call resilience reserve and we're
investing in startups that
in some meaningful way have the
potential to make the world more
resilient
and um you know so i'm investing with
that fund
so there's a lot going on lots of balls
in the air
dude that's so cool i knew about the
music thing but i didn't know about you
and chris
and creating a fund and yeah there's so
much
it's so impressive to see somebody who's
obviously
just worked and worked and worked at
different things and managed to get
themselves to a place where
they have expertise and contacts and
some leverage and some capital
and then when you pull all of that
together you can do some you can do some
pretty cool [ __ ]
yeah and you're doing some pretty cool
[ __ ] i'm amazed at the
just the quality of you know the quality
of your guests
the quality of the interviews and just
the frequency with which you're coming
out with episodes
is unbelievable so
yeah i mean i'm i'm also in quite a bit
of awe as a podcaster who
could never release episodes with a
frequency that you do even if i were
working a thousand hours a week
i'm gonna know what you're doing so you
keep up the good work too i appreciate
it robbery ladies and gentlemen rob
catch you next time all right see ya
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
face